welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar
discovering cellular mechanisms and
biomarkers and anti pd-1 non-responders
using ingenuity pathway analysis
software and ohmic soft on : data sets
from kyochon presented by dr. Devendra
mr. e senior field application scientist
kyochon advanced genomics my name is
xavier chairs and i will be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by kyochon for more
information about our sponsor please
visit www.globalei.com box our speaker
will respond to your questions via email
following the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the ask
a question box to let us know that
you're experiencing a problem this
presentation is educational and best
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. mystery I will
now turn the presentation over to him
Thank You Savior so this presentation we
are going to talk about how injury
patent office software and uncle and
software can be used in combination to
discover cellular mechanism and
biomarkers in anti pd-1 non-responder
datasets
just a quick legal disclaimer that the
product I'm going to show you are meant
for miscarry purposes as opposed to
diagnostic purposes
so as I mentioned in my title slide we
want to identify mechanisms action
biomarkers regulators and targets from
an anti pd-1 non-responder dataset I
want to clarify that this can be
actually done on any data set public or
your own
all right so user can also do a lot of
things I'm going to show you with their
own data set as well in part one of the
presentation we are going to focus on
data mining we're going to do that by
using uncle line from omics off so in
this case I'm going to introduce you to
what omics soft is and what Uncle land
is then using Uncle and software we
going to locate an N type 81
non-responder data set and later on
we're going to study some biomarkers
such as ug t 1 a 6 and a 3 and we're
going to study these biomarkers in more
details by exploring curated data from
TCGA and GTECH and then finally we are
going to associate this markers with
patient survival in part 2 we can should
study remaining of the data set right so
in a part 1 I just mentioned true genes
so in part 2 we're going to do data
interpretation using intuitive pathway
analysis we're going to learn about what
this software is and how it can be used
to study mechanism of action biomarkers
and regulators and then we will end with
a summary
so let me talk to you a little bit about
this case 30 right so interaction
between PD 1 and PDL 1 is a very
well-known immune checkpoint and that's
why there are so many drugs that are
designed to block this interaction one
of the drugs is nivel you map offered by
BMS this is also known as op deal so if
you watch TV you might have a Vincent
commercial for octavo it blocks PD 1 it
is used in indication such as melanoma
non-small cell lung carcinoma renal cell
carcinoma and others now the problem is
many PDL 1 expressing tumors they don't
respond to therapy
our whole question is why and as I
mentioned we want to start by maybe
locating an interesting data set so say
you were to do this on your own then
typically what you do is you would go to
a public domain so you you'll be going
to different sources are listed over
here such as TCGA geo and so on and then
you'll be locating interesting data set
or data sets right now if you want to
thoroughly study this data set then
you'll be first of all downloading that
if it is an NGS data set then you will
be cusing it as well so you'll be
checking like you know what is the
quality of reads and such afterwards
you'll be processing this data set
through secondary analysis pipeline so
again if it's an NGS data set that if
RIT you'll be mapping reads to the
reference and you'll be Q seeing like
you know okay how many these are map
which the communities are not map and
then finally you will do things such as
quantify gene and transcript expression
and then calculate differential
expression between groups of your
interest right so you might be comparing
non-responder versus responders which is
what we are going to do or you might be
comparing disease versus normal
treatment one versus treatment - right
this will depend on you but basically if
you were to be dealing with public data
set you'll be doing all of this right
now imagine you're really doing the same
thing with hundreds if not thousands of
public data set right because you want
to generate a powerful hypothesis or you
want to generate a powerful discovery
you would have to repeat this process
for hundreds if not thousands of data
set and in addition to that you would
have to curate metadata for all of this
data so each data set will have
description
what tissue is it coming from what cell
line is coming from if it's coming from
some sort of treatment or the drug
concentration what was the time for the
treatment its patient data or is it in
vitro data right so you'll be curating
all of this metadata as well
fortunately our omics off team has
already done all of this so they have
curated data from many different public
sources that are listed on the right
hand side such as TCGA which stands for
the Cancer Genome Atlas this has a lot
of tumor tissue information as well as
normal tissue information and normal
tissue will be adjacent to the tumor geo
which has a lot of public datasets
same with array Express CC le which has
cancer cell line information gtex which
has information for normal tissue right
so our team has gone through all of
these different public sources on the
left-hand side and curated a lot of data
and metadata furthermore all of this
expression data from public sources is
passed to the same pipeline so user can
do cross project and cross the cross
collection comparison
all of this is stored in omec soft lands
database which is the image on the lower
right corner and this database is
maintained and updated regularly so let
me tell you just a little bit more about
this database user can have access to
this database through a couple of
different products I have listed three
of those products over here one is on :
which has oncology data again from
sources such as TCGA geo ccle and others
disease land which has non oncology data
so this would be data relevant to
cardiovascular disease metabolic
diseases neurological diseases and
others and then finally genetics land
which has a lot of variant information
so this can be germline variants this
can be things like Jeeva and p-box
Association studies reference collection
and more and if you go to our website we
have greater description for all of
these products and the cool part is user
can also upload their own data have it
processed to the same pipeline and then
query across user data and public data
using this lens alright so in our case
because we are interested in anti pd-1
non-responder we are going to focus more
on on :
so first question we can ask is you want
to discover mechanism action target
smart marketer etc but first of all how
can we locate an interesting data set
using the software so in this case what
we are doing is we are opening up geo
collection within the software I have a
screen shot on the lower right corner
right and you can see this is a
point-and-click software right so it has
a GUI so you don't really need command
line knowledge but for those of you who
like to work with come online we also
offer API and again what we have done is
open up geo collection and at this point
user can search by variety of keywords
such as disease name drug name etc now
what we are interested in doing is we
want to locate a data set where we have
responders and non-responders
for anti pd-1 therapy right so we are
actually looking for patient data so in
the screenshot on my right hand side you
see I have selected subject treatment
pick filter so within software you can
specify that you're interested in
patient data as opposed to say in vitro
data so subject treatment will focus
more on patient data and over here when
you click on it you see an screen
opening up where I'm typing nivel you
map as soon as I start typing novel you
map some hits come up so I'm selecting
those hit and then pressing ok so when I
press ok what the software will do is it
will pull up all the patient studies
relevant to now volume app right and
those studies are listed in the bottom
table now one of the great things is our
team has curated metadata so you can
actually learn more about this study by
simply studying the table but you can
see that some also links as well so
reading the links you can read more
about this study and decide which
studies you want to focus on so in my
case I am focusing on this study with
GSD IDG SC six seven five zero one
why this specific study well in this
study authors are working with
metastatic renal cell carcinoma patients
they are administering this patients
with novel you map the study by the way
is performed at Johns Hopkins and
afterwards patients are classified as
dis ponders and non-responders as my
response evaluation criteria in solid
tumor afterwards they extract irony and
then use microarray and Illumina chip to
perform gene expression analysis what I
have over here is just summary of
matters if you want to read about this
in more details you can of course follow
the citation at the bottom and read
about this in a lot more details
so now that we have located interesting
study the question is can we look at the
gene expression data from this study so
we can again start identifying mechanism
of action biomarkers etc within the
software using the GSE ID number that I
emphasized on previous slides you can
easily open a couple of different views
when it comes to gene expression you can
open up a table view which I'm showing
you on the right hand side where you can
have a list of genes with differential
expression in terms of blocks will
change p-value adjusted p-value etc or
you can also open up a wall keno plot
which is in the left hand side and
volcano plot has a log for change on
x-axis and anti log or p-value on y-axis
so using either table or working a plot
you can study the genes are highly up
and down regulated and are significant
in our case we want to say start
discovering like biomarkers and targets
right so what do we do so in this case
we can study either table or or volcano
plot so in the table we are doing sorry
in the table and walking up what we are
doing comparison of responder versus
non-responders site so if you want to
focus on genes upregulated and
non-responders then we'll be focusing in
the upper left corner which is what i
have circle using the red circle and
when we focus on those genes what we
come across is a lot of you gt1 a
emphasize greatly on this you gt1 a
family members and that's why I'm going
to start discussion about them right so
one of the member they highly emphasized
on is ug to one a six and if you read
about these members then you quickly
realize that these members are involved
in metabolic and solute transport
functions so one can even propose a
hypothesis right now that you know one
of the ways and happily one
non-responders might be resisting the
therapy is your this genes might be
detoxifying exogenous and stress-related
lipids by breaking them down and excreta
them outside of the cells right so now
we have come across an interesting
mechanism of action a gene that can
potentially serve as both biomarker or a
targetable molecule so say you want to
learn more about this gene say you want
to know how this gene is expressed
across different tumor tissues and you
also compare things like how is it
access across tumor and normal tissue
what do you do within the software we
first open up geo collection right now
we are opening up TCGA collection the
Cancer Genome Atlas and as I mentioned
TCGA collection will have information
about tumor tissue as well as adjacent
normal tissue so when we search for this
gene with a few click we can easily open
up this chart and this chart will show
you how the scene is accessed across
different carcinoma and again I would
like you guys to remember that all of
the samples are processed using the same
pipeline you know this is something our
team has done very diligently and
because of that you can easily do
comparison in terms of how this gene is
expressed across different carcinoma so
in this case you can see this gene is
clearly expressed more in renal cell
carcinoma compared to something like AML
now say you want to focus more on
renewal carcinoma because our team has
also curated metadata and introduced
filters which you can see on the left
hand side you can easily click on renal
cell carcinoma disease filter and when
you do that you remove all of the other
diseases and you only keep renal cell
carcinoma and you can see what we see is
some blue samples and green samples so
blue samples are tumor samples and green
samples are just a normal sample so
right now they're in the same rule there
you want to split it into rows so
fortunately in this software you can
also help grouping options so you can
easily split that one row into two rows
where you can divide things between
tumor and normal and another thing you
can also do is turn on statistics so in
the lower right corner we have turned on
statistics so you can see at least ouz
to one a six there is some difference in
the sensor it's slightly more expressed
in tumor compared to normal
according to this chart and significance
wise it's more the line significant but
there's not a great difference now many
investigators will tell me that tumor is
not one thing right it has many
different stages so based on the
metadata that is curated by the team can
we split this into different stages of
tumor yes
it is very easy within the software you
can subgroup things into different
stages as you can see over here so now
tumor row is split into stage 1 2 3 4
etc and again you know difference wise
we see some difference but the
difference is not that great I mean
there is some difference between stage 1
& 2 2 & 3 etc but it's not that free now
keep in mind use each one a six it's
just one of the family members what
about other family members such as you
gt1 a three so we can also search for
ugt one a three and again we see the
same pattern that like you gg1 a 6 ug 2
1 a 3 is accessed also more in renal
cell carcinoma as opposed to say
something like
AML which is at the bottom of the screen
right like you did one a 6 we can flip
and filter and what we see is for ug 1 a
3 there's greater difference compared to
u21 a 6
and statistically speaking we also see
more see more significant p-value in the
lower right corner finally when we split
the tumor rule into different stages we
kind of see this increasing pattern as
we go from stage one to stage four so I
personally feel that most usually one is
a HC and six are expressed more in a
renal cell carcinoma compared to other
but usually what a three might have
better application as marker based on
the charts we have seen so far now the
problem here is many people don't like
the normal tissue that they see over
here because this is adjacent normal
tissue right so many people feel that
this adjacent normal tissue may or may
not be normal so what they want to do is
they want to compare tumor tissue from
TCGA with normal tissue from gtex data
base so gtx database by the way only has
information about normal tissues right
so they want to compare tumor tissue
from TCGA and normal tissue from gtex
and again because our team has
diligently curated all of the expression
data using the same pipeline and store
that in land database you can easily
make this comparison so you can open up
what we call virtual labs right so what
your lengths will be mixture of
different collections let's just teach
TCGA gtex and so on and using that you
can generate charts like the ones I'm
showing you over here and again I want
to emphasize this is like
point-and-click software if you want
come online then you have option for
that as well but you know if you don't
help command-line experience you can
easily still like point-and-click
and generate the charts like the ones
I'm showing you over here so in this
chart what we see is we have tumor from
TCGA as the top row solid tissue normal
which is the adjacent normal tissue from
TCGA as the second row and then finally
normal tissue from G text as the third
row what you see over here is there's
not much difference in expression
between normal of TCGA and gtex but
there's greater difference in expression
between both normals and tumor from TCGA
so again market applications wise you GT
Aug 1 80 might turn out to be a good
marker because this clear difference
between tumor and normal
again we can turn on statistics in the
software so in the lower right corner
you can see the p-value and it is
significant for this cross comparison
across three groups so in summary we
found that you gt1 a three and a six for
most Express more in renal cell
carcinoma compared to other tumors but
you GT one a three had greater
difference in expression between tumor
and normal tissue and this was true both
for TCGA tumor in normal and also TCGA
versus gtex tumor in normal and then you
gt1 a six can potential service marker
but it has it had lesser degree of
difference now one thing I do want to
remind you is I have gone through only
one or two collections like right like
so we went through TCGA geo but keep in
mind our curators helped curated data
from many other collections that are
listed in the lower left corner and one
of them collect one of these collections
is ccle which has cancer cell line
information so say you as a user might
want to investigate this in kept
different cancer cell line and you will
see similar conclusions in the sense
that you didn't want a six seems to be
excess more in kidney cancer cell line
as opposed to say a cairo cancer cell
line which is one of the cell lines at
the bottom
so what else can we do using the
software the answer is you can actually
do a lot of different things but one of
the other things that many users want to
do is they want to divide the samples
based on the criteria daily size so one
of this criteria can be expression
criteria so say you wanted to divide the
samples between samples that have high
expression of you gt1 a six and low
expression of you GT one a six then you
can very easily do that in this software
using what we call custom queries all
right so you can make a custom query for
you to you want a six like I have done
and you can divide samples that have
high expression off you GT one a six
versus low expression of ug one a six
and then once you divide snappa based on
the criteria you decide you can generate
many different types of plots like
survival curves heat map and other plots
as well so in this case say you wanted
to test the value of ug given a 6 as
prognostic marker then you will be maybe
looking at something like survival
curves and what you see is when you have
high expression of ug 1 a 6 which is the
blue line there is relative core
survival compared to when you have low
expression of ug t 1 a 6 now this is
across all TCGA tumors and if we look at
the log-rank test which in which is in
the upper right corner then we can see
this is a this seems to be significant
and we can do the same thing across
renal cell carcinoma patients right so
remember in this software we have
filters right so we can filter it for
only renal cell carcinoma and again we
see the same pattern in the sense that
when you have high you do t1 a 6
expression there is relatively poor
survival compared to when you have low
you gt1 a 6 expression though I have to
say that when I turn on the statistics
this does not turn out to be significant
nevertheless we can say that we are
seeing similar pattern and cool thing is
you don't have to stick with one marker
you can actually check this for you for
more number of markers as well so we're
here now we have two lines first line
the blue line is for samples that have
high expression of both ugt 1 8 3 and
usually want a 6
the second line green line is for
samples that have low expression of ug 2
and a 3 & a 6 and you can see when you
have high expression of both of these
markers a 3 & a 6 there is relatively
poor survival compared to when you have
low expression for both of these markers
and again I want to clarify this is
across all the tumors and if you look at
the p-value it is significant so my
summary for this would be there might be
some prognostic value for this you gt1 a
family member in the sense that when we
had high expression we saw relatively
poor survival across you know different
tumors and at least when we filter it
down to renal cell carcinoma for usually
one a6 it does not turn out to be
similar it does not turn out to be
significant but we still see similar
pattern as you know we would expect when
you have high expression there is for
survival compared to when you have low
expression there is slightly better
survival the major point I want to make
is user can choose to divide data based
on the criteria daylight right so in
this case we divide a sample based on
samples that had high expression of
usually one a six versus low expression
of fugitive one a six in your case you
can use gene of your interest so instead
of fugitive on a six you can take like
say ETF our or lag or whichever gene you
like and you can say okay device sample
based on high expression of this gene
versus low expression of this gene or
device sample based on high high
expression of gene one gene to and low
low expression of gene one scene two
and you don't have to just stick with
expression markers you can also divide
sample based on histological markers so
you can divide samples their her2
positive versus hard to negative triple
negative breast cancer versus non triple
negative breast cancer or go with
mutation markers samples are mutants for
tp53 versus wild coyote p53 the idea
here is once you divide sample based on
the criterias you like you can generate
many different types of plots that I am
showing you over here on this slide you
can generate survival curves so we have
survival curve for tp53 mutant versus
wall type patient in the I'm sorry
usually one a six mutant versus welfare
patient on the right hand side you can
also generate heat map so we see heat
map or comparing two different
ah parentis and you can also generate
things like alternative splicing view in
genome browser which is in the lower
left corner in addition to that I have
seen people working with artistic Fusion
copy number variation mutation viral and
bacterial count using uncle and software
so now that we have gone through data
mining you know now that we look at it
and interesting and I believe a
non-responder data set we also like
studied biomarkers such as ug to one a
three and a six across T C D and D tags
and associated them with survival let's
do interpretation you know so far we
have studied just two markets there were
also other genes that were significantly
up and down regulated so now we can ask
questions you know are they connected
with mechanism action are they connected
to potential biomarkers are they can
some of them be you know interesting
regulators and targets so IP is a
software where people typically start
with a table of molecules of the
interest so this molecules can be genes
right so in our case
we had this comparisons between
non-responder and responders and we had
lists of genes that were you know
differentially regulated so you can
start with a list of genes list of
transcript list of proteins list of
metabolites list of Micra and idea here
is you have a list but you don't know
you know what different molecules and
the in that list are doing what
different genes and proteins and that
list are doing so that's where injury
pathway analysis and its database come
into play so using this database in duty
pathway analysis is going to convert
this list into different visuals around
the life right hand side so now instead
of visualizing list you can see what
pathways this list is connected to what
biological processes this list is
connected with you can also open up
different pathways and processes and you
can see how different gene expression is
impacting different parts of the pathway
so you can study about mechanism actions
you can also study biomarkers through
creating bar charts and heat maps I'm
showing you on the right hand side and
you can also compare mechanism action
using the heat map so let me go into all
of this in more details the key here is
user has a list you know this can be
differential gene expression protein
list metabolite list and user is
confused like okay what is this list
related to so that's where IPA comes
into play and it will allow you to do
interpretation that I'm showing you on
the right hand side
so one of the reason IPL allows you to
do this is it is backed by this powerful
database this is what we call knowledge
based in this knowledge base we have
curation of peer-reviewed publications a
lot of this peer-review publication is
manually curated by phd-level scientists
and this is updated on weekly basis so
basically we have curation of high
quality information and this is updated
as frequently as weekly basis in
addition to that we also have curation
from third-party data sources so this
will be later social status
margarett which has protein-protein
interaction clinical trials.gov
which is information about clinical
trials powerbase which has information
about micro RNA human sake which is
information about metabolite and
pathways and such right so we curate
information our team creates information
both from peer review publications and
third-party data sources and one of the
great thing is this information curation
is quite contextual so say you upload a
list of genes or you upload two genes
then IP won't just show you that gene a
is connected to gene B it will give you
the context that this connection is
actually protein-protein interaction
this was discovered in humans in
such-and-such cell line this was
discovered by co-immunoprecipitation
experiment and most importantly it will
list the source this information is
coming from this specific publication
and if you click on the hyperlink next
to the publication it will also take you
to that publication and it will show you
the PubMed page for that publication so
you can dig into it in more detail and
see if you want to trust that
information or not but he here is we
have a database where our curators are
reading through text and figures of the
paper and manually curating a lot of the
information and that's why it is of such
great quality now
just to contrast this with the other
database that I mentioned earlier on :
right so in this database our curators
are going through text and figures and
curating knowledge as I'm showing you on
the right hand side in the other
database on colon database our curators
are curating actual and test data which
user can manipulate and generate
different charts that I showed you all
right so now you
we forward with IPA before I start
showing you some charts and figures and
such it's important to know some of the
legends that I'm listing over here so an
idea you're going to see many different
colors I request you to remember four of
them red green orange blue red and green
are from your data set so that other
data upregulated in your data set green
other genes are now regulated on your
data set and orange and blue are the
prediction IPA is making based on your
data set and information that's curated
from previous literature so for example
MSP one is colored red that means it's
up regulated in your data set so up
regulation of MSC one is leading to
increased apoptosis IPS making this
prediction based on the information that
is curated from previous literature
similarly mag is colored green so down
regulation of that seems to be leading
to decrease apoptosis so again bed is
now regulated in your data set and IPS
predicting according to previous
literature it will lead to reduce de
Pape doses similarly TGF alpha is color
red that means it's up in your data set
and this is going to lead to increased
activation of erbb2 also known as her
two so now that we understand some of
the basic legends say you were to upload
non-responder what's this responder
compares on an IPS so differential gene
expression for non-responder versus
responders so IPA will give you a list
of passwords I'm showing you over here
and then if you go to this path which
you will quickly realize that this
pathways are cancer related or are
related to growth Pro factor
inflammation and cell cycle
all of this are cancer related as well
so basically the top boxes we see in IPA
they're all cancer related for this anti
pd-1 non-responder datasets and you can
open up pathways so in this case to
study mechanism action we are opening up
molecular mechanisms can a molecular
mechanism of cancer pathway and you can
see pathways are nicely organized from
plasma membrane to nucleus in this case
we have plasma membrane both on top and
bottom and we are going to nucleus in
the center if we zoom in the pathway
then we can see the functional impact of
next question on this pathway so for
example in the center of the screen you
have NBS one color red so red means is
upregulated in your data set and this
seems to lead to increase DNA repair
because DNA repair is colored orange
similarly if you focus in the lower
right corner isn't that differential
gene expression is leading to increased
cell cycle and reduce apoptosis so now
what we are figuring out is differential
gene expression that is present in
non-responder versus responder is
needing to increase the any repair
reduce apoptosis and increase cell cycle
and this explains why non-responder
might be resisting the therapy similarly
you know if we look at the bottom part
of the pathway we see left one red red
is upregulated if you know about left
one left one is a cell survival marker
right if you did not know about it you
can easily find it out using IPS
database and what you can see that
upregulation of left one is also leading
to increased cell survival in anti PD
one non-responder so again this is
another way they might be resisting the
therapy now that we have talked about
mechanism of action
what about biomarkers what type of bomb
arc is going to discover it might be I
already mentioned one biomarker which is
left one but in IP you can turn on this
March heart and this march arts will
show you how left one is up and
non-responder which is a red bar and
down in responder which is the green bar
right so again we would expect cell
survival marker left to be up in
non-responder and down in responders and
there similarly other markers such as
the ones you see on the right hand sides
it is C D K and to see work three there
also all up in non-responder and down in
responder what if you did not know what
this marker were then you can easily use
Internet is beta base and figure out
what this markers are which is what I
have done over here so you can see
markers such as C CND 2 MB and left one
there off cell viability marker and
they're up in non-responder and down in
responder similarly other markers are
related to say cell proliferation such
as P sent to map kinase 30 they are also
up in non-responder and down in
responder and then finally you're like
okay you're telling me that this markers
are cell while daily tomorrow
because these markers are cell
proliferation markers based on what then
again in idea you can turn on this
relationship view page which will tell
you where this information is coming
from so for example ccnv two information
is actually coming from cell cultures
and it is coming from MK and forty five
cells as i'm showing you at the bottom
the authors have done si R any library
screening and you can actually go to the
specific publication list at the bottom
by clicking on the hyperlink and check
out this in more details if you want to
see how they derive this information so
you can always verify information when
it comes to biomarkers many users
actually want to find Mike biomarkers
based on other criteria so some users
for example they want to find biomarkers
based on their subcellular location so
say you are looking for biomarkers in
membrane then we also have true status
bar profiler which will allow you to use
various filters and focus on biomarkers
of your choice and over here we are
discovering that me two M can be one of
the membrane biomarker that you can
focus on in n type eighty-one
non-responders as I'm showing you over
here
now now that we have focused most on
mechanism action and biomarkers
what about regulators and targets so in
IPA we have some powerful tools such as
option analysis and causal network which
will allow you to focus on regulators
and targets using that I have discovered
over here many transcription regulators
that are connected to renal cell
carcinoma and also found to be activated
by IPA and you can see them in the
center of your screen and if you're
curious what this regulators are a lot
of these regulators are again involved
in processes of this cell cycle DNA
repair and such and similarly if you
focus on a genes such as GFP t1 and
smite 3 these are enzymes so if a user
is looking for targetable molecules now
you have targetable molecules IPA can
easily give you master regulators and it
can also provide you with some
interesting targets and say you wanted
to study this target in more detail so
say you wanted to study GFP t1 in more
detail you can actually open up the
network view and you can easily see how
GFP t1 is connected to renal cell
carcinoma so it seems that GFP t1 is
activating tgf-beta 1 make and tp53 and
this seems to be leading to increase
renal cell carcinoma phenotypes so while
we were looking for interesting target
we can also actually dive into mechanism
action and we can see how activation of
GFP t1 is leading to activation of
downstream regulators and how that is
leading to increase we know cell
carcinoma phenotype in anti PD one
non-responders and then finally for
those of you who might be interested in
drugs targeting different genes on this
network in IPS you can easily figure out
like you know which drugs can target
bitching so over here I have a drug
targeting tgf-beta 1 and you can find
out additional information about drugs
like is this drug this drug an agonist
antagonist
what clinical trials is this drug
involved in so in the table you can see
this drug is involved in different phase
1 phase 2 clinical trials
what is it it's an immunomodulator what
does it bind to it binds to different
members of tgf-beta 1 so what here I
have just turned on one drug
honestly you can turn on drugs for many
of the factors that you see on this
network over here right so again to
summarize we have looked at like one of
the mechanisms action example we have
looked at some biomarker example and we
have also looked at a regulator example
but so far we've been studying one thing
at a time right so we've been studying
like one mechanism action at a time
using a pathway we've been studying one
biomarker at a time and we've been
studying like one you know regular time
when we look at the network what is you
wanted to do comparison across multiple
networks multiple regulators in IPA you
can turn on this heat map and using this
heat maps you can compare multiple
groups right so over here what I have to
lie Pia is show me only cancer pathways
and show me how they are differentially
activated between non-responder and
responder datasets so in one problem I
have no responder which is the orange
column and other column I have responder
which is a blue column and orange in
blue again our prediction made by IPA
and you can see a lot of these cancer
pathways are on in non-responders and
all in responders so for those of you
again who are looking for mechanism of
action you can kind of see how different
cancer related pathways are on in non
responders and this can be one of the
ways non responders are resisting the
therapy furthermore if we dive deeper
into the pathway we can see the specific
like for example if we dive in a 7
signaling pathway then we can kind of
see CC and e3 is upregulated and that is
leading to proliferation of cells in
non-responder similarly other genes up
and down regulation seems to be leading
to reduce a pop to assist and altered
metabolism in terms of like increased
glucose uptake so in terms of mechanism
of action and generating hypotheses in
addition to looking at the vista heat
map you can also turn on network and
this networks will give you greater
insight
so let's take it a step further so so
far we've been comparing only two groups
from the data set that we are studying
which is the anti pity one non-responder
data set but there are other data sets
that are out there
in TCGA and geo that have to do with
renal cell carcinoma so now the question
is can we compare the data set yesterday
with public data set from TCGA NGO and
see if the mechanism of action is
similar or different across this
different renal cell carcinoma data set
and other thing we can also ask is you
know can disruption of different protein
lead to similar phenotype when we do
this comparison so as I mentioned
earlier on when I was covering on colon
from omics Hawk is in land you know our
curators have reprocessed all of the
expression data using the same pipeline
and what our IPA team has done is they
have uploaded many of this comparison in
IPA and then run core analysis on it and
now every single time you upload any
data set or any comparison IPA and by
comparison I'm talking about like
non-responder versus responder
comparison any time you upload such
comparisons your comparison is
automatically compared to other
comparisons and this other comparison
can be your own comparison or they can
be also public comparison so again in
simpler words your IPA analysis is
compared with your other IP analysis so
if you have treatment 1 it will be
compared to your treatment 2 3 4 and it
is also compared to public analysis of
different data sets so in this case we
are going to again compare and type
anyone non-responder data set with a
public renal cell carcinoma datasets so
for this we have a heat map and in this
heat map the left-hand most column is
more responder versus responder
comparison which we have been focusing
on so far and it is being compared to
different renal cell carcinoma data set
from public domain and you can see we
actually come up with some very
interesting comparison in the sense that
some of the data sets on the right hand
side that are in the bigger square these
are the data set where authors are
comparing visas and disease renal cell
carcinoma tissue versus normal renal
cell carcinoma tissue
and you can see the mechanism of action
we see in our renal cell carcinoma
dataset is similar to what we see in
this other public renal cell carcinoma
dataset and I don't have it on this
slide but the second-to-last dataset is
actually very interesting data set where
they use humanized mouse model and you
know that like shows similar behavior as
like human data sets and then in the
center you know I have also circled like
two columns and at the bottom I have
labeled M Burke 3 and II past one so
birth tree is a protein that's involved
in processes such as apoptosis invasion
cell cycle cells cell cycle and so on
and in class one has been shown to be
one of the anti tumor proteins in the
past and idea here is the comparison
you're seeing in the center is mutant
versus wild type for these genes so you
can imagine if you were to produce
mutation in a gene that is involved in
apoptosis cell cycle or in tumor
suppression you might get a profile that
is more similar to tumor and that's
exactly what we see in that Center right
so my biggest conclusion on this slide
would be that mechanism of action that
we see on in non-responder is also on in
other denote cell carcinoma data set
from public domain and then in terms of
which data set is coming from which
study you can easily click on the title
and you can find out more about the
study by looking at the table within the
software so this table will give you a
link to the study so you can go on that
link and read more about it but in
addition it will give you information
such as if the authors are using
microarray or RN C or what type of
tissue they're using what type of cell
line they're using what exactly are they
comparing what type of statistical test
they're doing all of this is easily
visible within the software by simply
clicking on the title now using heat map
if you want to study mechanism or action
in more detail so for example if you
come across interesting regulators such
as cd44 OSM and you wanted to know how
this regulators are connected to tumor
genesis of tissue you can easily click
on the squares next to them and you can
open up that network and then later
you can connect that Network emergents
the tissue which I have done on the
right hand side so now you're not just
saying that mechanism of action is
similar we can say the mechanism action
that is leading to two emergencies of
tissue is similar between anti pd-1
non-responder and other renal cell
carcinoma data set and then finally I
want to make a distinction over here
many times people can confuse this heat
map with gene expression heat map so
keep in mind the heat map that I have on
the left hand side which has orange
color this is not a gene expression heat
map in this segment what IP is doing is
based on your gene expression data set
it is determining what factors and what
path they should be on or off right so
it determined that OS m should be on and
it has colored a orange but now you're
wondering like why OS M is turned on you
can also generate another heat map in
IPA which I'm showing you on the right
hand side so the gene heat map sorry
heat map on the right hand side is the
gene expression heat map and this gene
expression heat map shows why oh if M is
on because many of the downstream
factors of OS m are also up regulated
and that's why for M is on so this is a
very important distinction the heat map
on the left hand side is activity heat
map the heat map on the right side right
hand side is gene expression heat map
and by looking at gene expression heat
map we can also discover other
biomarkers there on not only in
non-responder but also in many of the
public datasets that we see on the right
hand side so instantly what we did is we
learn the mechanism of action by looking
at both pathways and networks so if you
remember we looked at molecular
mechanism of cancer pathways and we
learned how differentials in gene
expression was leading to increased DNA
repair reduce apoptosis and increased
cell cycle and we also looked at
interesting networks that this GFP t1
network where we saw increase in tj1
activity also increase in tp53 activity
and how that was leading to increased
renal cell carcinoma phenotype in
addition to that we also studied some
biomarkers that is left 1cc and e2 and
others which are showed both as bar
chart in the lower left
the screen and gene expression heat map
and then finally we also compare
mechanism action between data set of our
interest which is a non respondent data
set with public data set and this is the
heat map that has orange color at the
bottom right now what I did not go over
is a scenario where user does not have
data set so keeping this study in mind
to your user you don't know anything
about you gt1 a six which is what we
studied earlier on and you're like okay
how is you gt1 a six connected to renal
cell carcinoma even without data set you
can generate the network I'm showing you
on the right hand side where you just
simply search for usually one a six in
the search bar grow a network out of it
and connect it to renal cell carcinoma
and this is how you can easily figure
out that you gt1 a six can interact with
other family members which is you gt1 a
three a seven as well as other genes
such as androgen receptor and this is
how it can make connection to renal cell
carcinoma right so idea here is the
software i'm showing you you don't need
to have a data set to use them even
without data set you can generate
network and using those networks you can
generate hypotheses designed downstream
experiments and so on
so my overall summary would be we looked
at two different software and two
different data bases so one software was
uncle and from omics walks and other
software was in judah pathway analysis
to contrast the database is backing
district software on colons database has
curation of actual NGS data which is
reprocessed using the same pipeline and
user can manipulate this data to
generate expression charts volcano plot
provoker heat map that i'm showing you
in the upper right hand corner as
opposed to that injury pathway analysis
has a different type of database
ingenuity package analysis database user
employee curators are reading through
text and speakers of journal articles
and creating information right so it
might have NGS information but then in
addition to that you would have
information about like western blots and
so on
so in in unities knowledgebase
people are curating information from
text and figures as opposed to that in
uncle lines knowledge base
we are curating actual and just data and
that's why this two databases they are
so complementary to each other and then
can be used in combination to do many
different types of discovery so I
already mentioned discoveries by uncle
and database now for internet database
we did discovery in terms of we looked
into the mechanisms action we looked at
biomarkers we also compared our analysis
with public analysis so using this to
database and software in combination you
can actually do variety of discoveries
and I have only outlined some of them in
my presentation today so with that I
want to quickly thank my colleagues who
have helped me generate this
presentation and if you guys have any
questions I am happy to take them right
now
thank you dr. mystery for the
informative presentation I would also
like to thank kya Jen for making today's
educational webcast possible and before
we go I want to let everyone know that
this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2018 as
a final reminder our speaker will follow
up with any questions you submitted via
email that's all for now thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon goodbye